بوتين خلف قفص الاتهام امام قاضن وهيئه من
المحلفين ربما يكون هذا السيناريو اجمل
حلم على الاطلاق لزيزلنسكي الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين مطلوب اليوم للمحاكمه
مذكره اعتقال بحق الزعيم روسيا اصدرتها
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه والتهمه
الاشتراك في جريمه حرب تتمثل في الترحيل
غير القانوني للاطفال من المناطق المحتله
في اوكرانيا الى روسيا
الغرب سارع الى الترحيب بالخطوه لكن هناك
في الكرملين
ان هناك عده زعماء سبق ان حكموا في تلك
المحكمه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في
لاهاي جزء من نظام العداله العالمي 123
دوله من حول العالم صادقت على قانون روما
الاساسي الذي انشا المحكمه وتهدف الى
محاكمه المسؤولين ومقاضاتهم عن اسوا
الجرائم التي يرتكبها البشر مثل جرائم
الاباده الجماعيه والجرائم ضد الانسانيه
وجرائم الحرب المحكمه تتمتع بولايه قضائيه
عالميه وتعد الملاذى الاخيره عندما تفشل
كل السبل المحليه والدوليه الاخرى في
توقيف مجرمي الحرب الرئيس اليوغزلافي
السابقان كان من ابرز من وقفوا امام
المحكمه اتهمته بارتكاب اباده جماعيه
وجرائم ضد الانسانيه خلال الحرب في
البوسنه وكرواتيا وكوسوفو الا ان
ميلوزوفيتش الذي استغرقت محاكمته نحو خمس
سنوات توفي في زنزانته عام 2006 قبل صدور
الحكم بحقه واول حكم للمحكمه صدر في مارس
عام 2012 ضد توماس لوبانغا زعيم احدى
العسكريه في جمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه
ادين وقتها بارتكاب جرائم حرب تتعلق
باستخدام الاطفال في صراع المسلح وحكم
عليه بالسجن اربعه عشر عاما
ومن ابرز الشخصيات التي اصدرت المحكمه
مذكرات توقيف بحقهم رئيس السودان السابق
عمر البشير وزعيم ليبيا السابق معمر
القذافي
ولايه سيدي
لا نعترف بها وقراراتها باطله بتلك
الكلمات جاء رد الكرملين على قرار المحكمه
فروسيا ثاني اقوى دوله في العالم لا تعترف
بتلك المحكمه كما هو الحال في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين لكن هناك فكيف
هناك من يعول عليها كخطوه اولى على طريق
زج بوتين خلف القضبان بحسب ما ياملون
مبغومه
قرار الجنائيه الدوليه سيبقى حبرا على ورق
طالما لم قدم بوت ارض احدى الدول الاعضاء
فيها كما ان المحكمه لا تستطيع محاكمه
المشتبه بهم غيابيا وحتى وان حدث وسافر
بوتين الى احدى تلك الدول فنادرا ما تقوم
الدول الاعضاء بتنفيذ مذكرات التوقيف فما
بالكم عندما يكون المتهم فلاديمير بوتين
زعيمه ثاني اقوى دوله في العالم